viii
good evening and welcome to the rare
book room my name is Cynthia and I
direct the events here at strand where
books have been loved for 89 years and
Counting
dr. Danielle Ofri is the physician at
Bellevue Hospital the oldest public
hospital in the country and associate
professor of medicine at NYU she writes
about medicine and the doctor-patient
connection for the New York Times and
other publications she is also
co-founder and editor in chief of the
Bellevue literary review the first
literary journal to arise from a medical
setting her critically acclaimed book
what doctors feel has been a Strand
bestseller for some time now and we're
sure her new book what patients say what
doctors here will enjoy the same success
please join me in welcoming dr. Danielle
Ofri to the Strand
[Applause]
hi thank you it's so nice to be here the
strands always been a perennial favorite
of mine and regular New York City haunts
since I was a medical student the one
dollar book bin and the was one of my
major food groups along with coffee
getting through those years um this
morning I was seeing patients at
Bellevue at a regular clinic session you
know a busy day lots of patients lots of
medications lots of illness and like
many other doctors I'm always wondering
am I really as good as I could be should
I be improving a little bit and I think
we do certain things to make ourselves
better continuing medical education me I
go through these periodic kind of spring
cleaning frenzies maybe I'll pull out my
physical exam book and commit myself
learning how to palpate the spleen again
we're all swear that I'm gonna read the
New England Journal of Medicine every
week and not just scan the headlines a
couple months ago I recertified for my
boards and so I memorized 2,000 pages of
facts which I retain for about 72 hours
but I never really thought much about
how I speak with patients and before I
wrote this book I I viewed communication
not much differently than I viewed
breathing you know I kind of did both
automatically I only really paid
attention if they ceased and as I I
started writing this book when I had the
opportunity to interview a doctor and a
patient a pair who'd been together for a
couple of years and what was fascinating
is that when they told the story of the
same events it was completely different
almost like two movie cameras on one set
of events or almost at times like two
different movies and I was fascinated by
the gap between what patients say and
what doctors here and and and vice versa
and when we think about what values what
matters most in the doctor-patient
interaction and we have you know lots of
high technology now which I love but as
I spend time reading the research and
talking with doctors and patients I
really ended up concluding that the
doctor/patient conversation is the
single most powerful diagnostic tool
that we have and often one of the most
powerful therapeutic tools that that we
have
and it feels anachronistic to say that
given the age of you know genomic
medicine and we have fancy scans and
MRIs and and now chemotherapy that can
act exactly on your tumor yet the way we
communicate is so important and often
get such short shrift I mean when you
look at what insurance companies pay for
it's not time to talk with your doctor
but it's what procedure you got what to
button to which orifice or which surgery
you had or the medications that you get
but the idea of doctors and patients
speaking it's considered oh that's kind
of a nice little affable bonus a good
bedside manner but I hope that in
writing this book I'll help doctors and
patients and maybe insurance companies
and perhaps those who are redoing our
healthcare as we speak
might come to value the time that
doctors and patients actually talk
together is something worthy of counting
and and reimbursing for and valuing it
in our time so I wanted to start by
sharing a patient of mine I've changed
the name and some details who
exemplifies some of the challenges in in
in communication it was late on a
Thursday evening when my office phone
rang it was Omar Amadou I am not feeling
well he said I need to see you doctor oh
free the clinic was already closing up I
had already turned off the computer and
you see you now mr. Amadou said the
annoyance in his voice was apparent even
with his thick West African accent in
the few months I had known mr. Amadou I
probably fielded 50 phone calls from him
he always had something wrong something
bothering him or needed a forum filled
out a medication renewed and he always
needed it right away he constantly
showed up at the clinic without an
appointment but he also had a severe
heart condition even though he was only
43 at her first visit he'd hauled out a
tome of papers from a cardiologist
cardiologist in Pittsburgh that detailed
a severely malfunctioning heart one that
required a pacemaker a defibrillator and
several stays in the ICU
so he calls on a Thursday evening I took
his concerns seriously despite the
irritating tone of his voice and my
depleted reserve of patience for him I
questioned him about his symptoms to
suggest if he had congestive heart
failure or an arrhythmia things I said
it right to the ER for but he had no
specific symptoms just a vague sense of
not feeling well I wasn't scheduled to
be in the clinic the following day
Friday but because of his poor heart I
didn't feel comfortable waiting until
Monday please come to the clinic
tomorrow I said I explained that I
wouldn't be there but he would be seen
by one of my colleagues when I arrived
on Monday morning there was an indignant
voicemail message from mr. Amadou I come
Friday but you know there so I go home I
need to see you either
he hadn't understood what I said or he
was simply being stubborn the next three
days were a series of missed phone
messages between us if he was feeling
sick I told him he should come to Urgent
Care right away if he didn't feel too
bad we could get him a regular
appointment he left repeated voicemail
saying I need to see you dr. Overy
seeming not to acknowledge any of my
messages to him and whenever I called
back I only got his voicemail midday the
following Thursday just as I was saying
goodbye to the last of the morning
patients mr. Amin who popped into my
line of sight tall and lanky dressed in
a powder blue tracksuit he signal
anxiously at me I need to see you dr.
Ofra he called that it is very important
I was unprepared for the rush of anger
that fluttered me miserable you could
just walk in the door and assume I would
drop everything and give him an instant
and medical evaluation yeah he had a bad
heart and all but that didn't give him a
free pass to be so demanding obviously
whatever was bothering him couldn't have
been so bad because he chosen to spend
the week trading messages with me rather
than coming to the clinic I needed to
draw a line mr. Amadou I said you cannot
just show up to the clinic without an
appointment I come here to see you
doctor Oh free he said yes I know I said
but I have other patients with scheduled
appointments if it's something that's
urgent you can come to the walk-in
clinic today
otherwise you need to make an
appointment like everyone else I know
see other doctor mr. Robert who said I
only want to see you I need to see you
today
I knew that if I gave mr. Amadou a
medical visit right now I'd reinforce
the idea that he could just walk into my
office at any time he'd be at my
doorstep every week but I also
understood the severity of his
cardiomyopathy this was not the type of
patient I could take a chance on
annoying or not
okay mr. Amadou I said sighing heavily
just a quick visit next time you have to
make an appointment mr. Amadou smiled
broadly as I led him from the waiting
room and I knew I was going to regret
this decision
he'd now figured out how to get in
instant appointment just be annoyingly
persistent until I caved the medical
assistant was about to leave for lunch
but I gave him beseeching smile could
you please do a quick set of vital signs
that mr. Alma do I asked he hesitated
raised an eyebrow and then finally
assented with relief i gestured mr.
Amadou to enter the assistance room mr.
ramadhir took two steps and then paused
in mid footfall he seemed to hold his
lanky body aloft almost as though the
muscles were debating whether to move it
forward or backward but it was all an
illusion as he collapsed to the floor
with a heart-stopping thud I dropped to
my knees and pressed my fingers to his
neck to check a pulse
mr. Amadou I shouted can you hear me he
was breathing rapidly slumped against
the doorframe his legs stretched out
into the hallway he placed his right
hand over his chest my heart
he said faintly and I was swamped with a
horrific wave of guilt I called for
oxygen in the stretcher
while crammed my stethoscope under the
jacket of his tracksuit his pulse is 130
his fingers were so cold that the oxygen
saturation monitor could not pick up a
reading we loaded his listless body onto
the stretcher and began wheeling him to
the rack to the emergency room
disconsolate I held mr. almond whose
hand as we pressed down the hall
striding briskly to keep my pangs of
remorse at bay praying that he was going
to be okay we rolled him into the triage
Bay of the emergency room and I
explained the situation to the ER
as we finished the handoff of medical
care I turned back to mr. Amadou I took
his cool clammy right hand in my two
hands and gave it a squeeze his fingers
were frigid I apologized for berating
him in the waiting room and for all of
our miscommunications during the week he
opened his eyes to my words but was too
breathless to speak he nodded slightly
and then squeeze my hand weakly I
trudged back to the clinic staring down
at the linoleum floor the whole way I
couldn't hold back from dissecting in
minut detail the events that have just
transpired trying to figure out the
mistakes mr. Amadou had been demanding
for how perhaps unreasonably so and I
put my foot down maybe a bit too
decisively but maybe the problem was
more basic than that maybe we just
weren't hearing each other George
Bernard Shaw supposedly said the single
biggest problem in communication is the
illusion that it has taken place so as I
began going into the research I really
became intrigued about how we actually
study communication the field of
communication research comes from
English teachers who were interested in
public speaking and they promulgated the
idea that the way you convey information
is that the speaker stands up says what
they have to say
loud and clear and like sending off like
a basket on a zip line to the audience
and they unpack it and they get the
information and there's some fascinating
studies done by a researcher named Janet
Bevelle as' in the west coast of Canada
and she was interested and how the
listener affects the speaker she did a
very clever study with some college
students and she took pairs of students
and one student was told to tell a story
from their life some near-miss something
very dramatic that almost happened or
almost fell or almost lost their life
and the other person had to listen so
with one group of listeners they told
them that while the speaker was speaking
they had to count in their head the
number of holiday school holidays
between now and Chris
and it was February in the exam during
the during the study so while the
speaker spoke the other students
thinking okay there's Valentine's Day
and MalK a day Columbus Day and trying
to figure how many holidays that were
off so unsurprisingly they were allows e
listeners they hardly noticed was being
said they didn't do much in the way of
sort of generic aha nodding to let you
know they're listening and they gave
almost no specific responses like
responding to key parts of the story for
the second set of listeners they had
those listeners press a button each time
the speaker used a word beginning with
the letter T so these speaker these
listeners had to listen very attentively
and mark each time there's a word with a
T now these speakers actually did pretty
well with with the nonspecific responses
like a huh and yeah but they're equally
bad at giving specific responses so they
were listening hard but they weren't
actually hearing the story but the most
amazing thing to me was the effect on
the speaker as the speaker began to talk
and realized the person wasn't listening
they began to falter they would circle
back and tell the story again because
there was a dramatic near miss story and
they'll hear listener wasn't getting it
so they say it again and the story will
begin to break down and essentially
collapse in into nothing and so she
termed the idea that the speaker that
the listener is a co narrator they help
the speaker narrate the story and that
when they listen well the speaker tells
a better story when they listen poorly
the story breaks down and I think this
has a lot of relevance to doctors and
patients because when a patient tells
the story and I think many of you may
know the situation you're telling the
story and if the doctor is checked out
or they're on the computer or looking so
else something else up you kind of stop
you feel a little silly speaking into
into the air and if we listen better
then the story comes out more whole and
and much better so one of the things
doctors do is we interrupt patients very
quickly something like 8 to 10 seconds
you say I'm having this kind of pain oh
when did to start whole reason I said
why is it worse right we just can't help
ourselves
so I wondered how long would a patient
speak if you didn't say a thing just let
him go and I pulled my colleagues so I'm
like oh five minutes 10 minutes 20
minutes forever I would never do with my
patients so I found a study that
actually did that a Swiss study where
they the doctor said what can I help you
with today then the patient just spoke
and the doctors didn't say a word other
than nod and hmm and the average
monologue for the patient 92 seconds
right
hardly the deluge you know it tsunami
that we we fear I thought okay I'm going
to try this in my clinic so the very
next day I did it so for every patient
after I said what can I help you with I
turned on my stopwatch and I didn't say
a word just took notes as I spoke and I
just nodded
so the first patient was about 38
seconds but they were pretty healthy and
the next patient had a little bit of
back pain you know a minute a minute and
a half not too bad but then came the
kicker
Josephina virus and a teacher in her
native Argentina
Josefina Garza was saddled with a vast
array of insoluble pains compounded by
anxiety depression and irritable bowel
syndrome plus a demanding mother to care
for exactly the type of patient who can
drown you with her list of complaints I
love her droll observations about New
York City's pretensions of culture which
of course could never measure up to the
sophistication of Buenos Aires but if I
let her talk uninterrupted this visit
would unfurl a cab or haze labyrinth I'd
hear a dizzying list of symptoms from
every organ a rundown of her mother's
medical ills plus a stinging critique of
metropolitan operas soulless production
of Turandot I wouldn't be able to
provide any easy solutions for her
symptoms and I'd be forced to explain
the decisions of her mother's doctors as
well as the artistic director of the met
who desiccates Puccini and a routine
basis both of us would be in a sour mood
by the end and the whole thing would
turn out to be sprawling onerous myths
worthy of an atonal Schoenberg opera
which miss gars of course would
excoriate and philosophical Graham
but I promised myself I'd let every
single patient talk today if I
eliminated the so-called difficult
patients then my data however informal
would be flawed I guarded myself for
battle and asked ms garza how can I help
you today and reluctantly quit gon stop
wash every single thing hurts she said
from my toes to my head there were
shooting pains in her gums her scalp was
painfully sensitive neck pain was
radiating down her spine
her mother had insomnia I was up at all
hours of the night complaining each time
she pause I said gamely anything else
and there always was I'm only 45 she
said but I feel like I'm 85 every step
hurts and my head feels like it's
swollen to five times its size it's like
I'm walking through molasses I scribbled
a few notes on paper as she talked but
maintained eye contact with her the
entire time let's get everything on the
table
I said bracingly every last symptom and
then we'll well I'm will figure out
where to go from there
a little keep talking until she fully
truly absolutely come to the end of all
she had to say in the dip of silence I
reached over to click off a stopwatch I
estimated 8 minutes 10 minutes it
transpired but in fact it went 4 minutes
and 7 seconds and the met had come out
unscathed I suppress the urge to jump up
and say Wow instead I turned back to
miss Carson said is that everything and
she nodded I showed her the list I'd
been jotting down when viewed on the
page it actually didn't seem so
overwhelming it was long but it was
finite miss scars had already had the
million-dollar workup which was all
negative I explained to her that she had
something going on medicine is very poor
at explaining pain syndromes I said but
that doesn't mean we can't go ahead and
start treating the symptoms we went down
the list together trying to identify
which pains might be helped with ice
packs which might be treated with local
heat and massage which might be best
treated with physical therapy which
might respond to pain medications we
talked about how antidepressants could
be helpful and that seeing a therapist
could decrease her stress we discussed
we discussed the critical role of
exercise and treating chronic pain
and then we brought up a plan at the end
of the visit shouldn't run over time by
too much she said something that I'd
read about but never actually heard a
patient legitimately say just talking
about all this she said has made me feel
better I wanted to jump up and sing an
aria which luckily for all parties
involved I refrain from but I was in the
process of realizing something else just
talking it all out made me feel better I
think that most doctors they were really
honest with you would say we hate
patients like miss Garza those patients
would come in with a million complaints
a list of mile-long 50 questions 20
medications 16 things download from the
internet we'd read these patients of
course we say we want informed patients
we want them to take you know control
things but it's really hard you have 15
minutes and a lot to get through
especially we feel like we can't do very
much because so many of their issues
relate to their life in general there
are socio-economic issues there's stress
in their life their lousy job their bad
shoes things we often don't have much
role in in in affecting and these are
the patients who get shunted from Doctor
to doctor because I think that we
doctors we try to turn off the spigot as
expeditiously as possible get them to
stop talking just the more they say the
more we have to deal with and so what I
learned from miss Garza that actually
letting it all come out in fact maybe
visit more efficient it felt like a lot
but once we got all on the page it
really wasn't so bad and we couldn't
handle all today but it was alright
let's let's do the top three let's save
the next four for the next visit and
then I think she felt less anxious that
it that she wasn't gonna have to jump it
with one more thing we could get it all
out and then she I think was able to
calm down a bit now it's interesting we
do a lot of research and medicine on the
effect of the medications we prescribe
the tests we do were always interested
in the outcomes of what we do we want
everything to be evidence-based medicine
this is there any evidence for how we
speak and how we as doctors talk to
patients change the medical outcome
there was a landmark study back in
1964 patients were going for abdominal
surgery and if indeed you've ever had
abdominal surgery you know that post-op
pain is a terrible problem and we tend
to treat a post-op pain with narcotics
they work well but of course they cause
a host of problems nausea vomiting
constipation respiratory arrest and loss
of consciousness so minimizing narcotic
use is an enormous priority for for
people in the medical profession so with
this very simple study did is they took
a hundred patients who are going for
surgery the next morning and the night
before surgery
you know the anesthesiologist goes and
talks to each patient and explains it's
gonna happen but for half the patients
randomly chosen the anesthetist also
gave a 20 min discussion about post-op
pain they explained what the pain is how
it's often caused by clenching muscles
where the pain might occur when it might
occur how you might relax your muscles
to ease the pain in fact didn't work how
to call the nurse or pain medications
that's it 20 minutes and the surgeons
who operated and took care of the
patients had no idea who was in what
group and I think we might be able to
guess that those patients had you know a
little better pain relief but what was
amazing is that they needed half the
amount of narcotics and the other
patients that's an enormous clinically
significant decrease I mean for me
internist anything that decreases the
amount of constipation that patients get
is worth a gold medal in and of itself
but more amazingly those patients were
discharged three days earlier than the
other group in today's dollars that's
almost $15,000 in cost plus you know
three days in the hospital when you
could be at home so a simple
intervention of speaking to patients of
explaining what's gonna happen no rocket
science here really changed outcomes in
a meaningful way there's a more recent
study involving physical therapists and
back pain and it's one of my favorite
studies because back pain is probably
the number one thing I see in clinic
people come in everyone's back hurts and
you know it's just part of life but it's
probably the third leading cause of
doctor's visit so I didn't use an
enormous amount of resources time money
medications physical therapy
and so when I send my patients for
physical therapy which is my preferred
mode of treatment I always think in
terms of oh the exercises the physical
therapists will do the massage the ways
of lifting that they'll instruct the
patient on sometimes they'll use
electrical stimulation which is can be
very helpful but I don't think about is
how the physical therapist communicates
with the patient and this very clever
Canadian study took a bunch of patients
with back pain going for physical
therapy and divided them in half half
got the treatment the the electrical
stimulation and half got sham you hook
the whole thing up and don't even turn
it on at all and they said oh this new
machine is very quiet doesn't make any
sound at all right the latest the
technology and the people who got the
stimulation they did better than the
placebo group right they had about if
25% reduction in their level of pain and
I'm sorry the people who got the Sham
stimulation they had a 25% reduction in
pain so just having the whole setup
relieve pain but those who got the
actual stimulation had a 45% reduction
of pain so the the simulation actually
works but then they divide each group in
half again and half the physical
therapists were very engaged with the
patients they asked them about the pain
how the pain fits into their life how it
limits their activity they expressed a
lot of empathy they really actively try
to make a good doctor/patient connection
they expressed optimism that the pain
would get better and those patients who
got no stimulation at all
the machine was off but got engaged
therapists had a 55 percent reduction in
pain that's more than the machine itself
by itself what we say was more powerful
than the machine the patients who had
both the Machine and the engaged
physical therapists had a 75 percent
reduction in pain they really benefit
and again it didn't take very much right
it just took a little bit more attention
to speaking that the visit wasn't any
longer but the after the physical
therapist
connecting communicating empathizing
made a real difference in the patient's
pain and you can say oh this is just
hokey placebo and it might be but if you
have back pain and you get 75% reduction
your pain
which is you know 45 percent that is
meaningful and I want my physical
therapist one of my patients once said I
don't care it's a dill pickle if it
makes you feel better
reduces that pain I'll take it and the
idea of placebo you know comes up he
says something that's unethical to give
a patient placebo doesn't actually help
I'm going to share with you which is one
one last story and this patient that
this story takes back it takes place
when I was a resident and so I trained
at Bellevue during the height of the
AIDS epidemic and so the eighth word
ability was a very very busy place it
was well past midnight on the AIDS ward
at Bellevue despite the late hour nurses
and doctors were still rushing about a
full speed as the admissions continued
to surge in each more feverish and
emaciated in the previous but even the
AIDS ward eventually quieted down at
night except that is for the howler the
howler was a patient in his 30s who
earned his nickname for his nightly
bouts of whaling he was already getting
hefty doses of pain medications yet he
kept screaming to the nurses about his
pain this one on night after night
despite extensive medical evaluations to
see if there are any missed explanations
for his pain nothing seemed to help and
the nightly alan was agitating the other
patients not to mention driving the
nursing staff a distraction the head
nurse paged me stat paged me three
o'clock in the morning you have to do
something she said before somebody
strangles him reluctantly I trudged back
into the patient's room I've been on my
feet for more hours than I could count
this was my fourth visit to the howler
that night by this point we were both
pretty exasperated with each other he
was sullen and cranky I was exhausted
and at my wit's end
I watched the patient writhing in pain
and felt bad for him but his moans
burrowed into my brain deflating my last
three functioning neurons I rummaged
around my pockets but in my pockets to
see what I could come up with and pulled
out a vial of saline on a whim I plucked
a syringe from another pocket and slowly
peeled back the wrapper stepping in
closer to the patient's bedside
i cocked back the syringe and drew up
one cc of plain saline you know about
tylenol right I said to the patient who
is continuing to twist within his bed
sheets and you've heard of tylenol
number three the kind of codeine right
I leaned for and held up the liquid
filled syringe close to the patient's
face there's even a Tylenol number four
I slowly slowly remove the cover off the
needle and it glistened in the
fluorescent lights but this and here I
pause for dramatic effect this is
tylenol number five the patient stopped
howling and gave me an interested look
without a word he lowered his pajamas
allowed me to inject the Saline into his
gluteus maximus I disposed of the
syringe in the nearby sharps box and
then pulled up a chair to his bedside
the patients and I waited together
allowing the minutes to tick on
hurriedly by after what seemed like a
mutually agreeable time I stood up and
bid him goodnight the patient put his
head on the pillow and promptly fell
asleep the ward was silent for the rest
of the night I did feel guilty that I
committed an outright deception with
this patient something I knew was a true
no-no on the other hand was the first
time he got a full night of sleep say
nothing of all the other patients on the
wards the rest of the staff the nurse by
the way bought me coffee and Danish the
next morning she was my best friend for
the rest of residency and the idea of
placebo is this fascinating thing we
think of placebo as the you know the
sugar pill we use in a clinical trial
that the nothing part but if you look at
the data around placebo placebo always
has an effect and I mean before we had
antibiotics or MRIs or chemotherapy or
lung transplants placebos what doctors
did
it's what shaman's did so what which
doctors did it's what of all people the
medical profession did we had nothing
else and in many cases it was remarkably
effective many people get better with
placebo and placebo can be a number of
things and we we know that it probably
activates the endorphin system the very
interesting study was done just on the
techniques of placebo where they took
normal volunteers and gave them
painful stimulus a hot pad on their calf
and then dripped an IV of pain
medication equivalent of fentanyl to
relieve the pain and they had their
heads nicely in a functional MRI and so
first they gave the pain painful
stimulus and they let the fentanyl drip
in unannounced and the patient's pain
got better afterward my fentanyl
certainly worked then they said they
gave the painful stimulus and they said
and now we'll start the pain medication
and their pain got even better about
twice as good just by making that little
announcement and then they said they
gave the painful signals again we're now
gonna stop the fentanyl because we're
worried that there's a rebound for
increase in pain but they still gave it
finally and in fact there was no benefit
at all the entire effect of fentanyl was
wiped out by saying it's not going to
help you and when they did the fMRI they
could see that the pain regions of the
brain lay light up whether you give the
pain medication just say you're going to
get the pain medication so it seems to
have a neurological effect and again if
it works why not
as long as we're not you know skipping
out on another and you know a necessary
medication and so I kind of look at
placebo differently now I used to think
of sort of unethical but now I think
it's unethical not to give it a try in
situations where someone's not getting a
relief by traditional means and so one
of my favorite was he bows now is the
multivitamin and I always had patients
come and say I had a patient this
morning's that you know I need a
multivitamin me more energy if I take a
vitamin and of course the answer is no
you know I I there's no study just to
support that and I would normally say
hey you know you know take it if you
want it's just gonna be a waste of your
money if you don't provide them a
deficiency it's useless but you don't
take it if you want but now I say you
know many of my patients say that taking
a multivitamin gives them a lot of
energy it's not alive because lots of my
patients do say that and I let them take
it and if it helps great you know I made
them better as long as I'm not skipping
out on their blood pressure medication I
don't see any harm in that
and you can let them know that it may
work as a placebo and in fact
surprisingly open-label placebos can
really help there's a study of patients
with irritable bowel syndrome which they
were given a placebo
said told this is a placebo there's
nothing in here but there's a lot of
research to show that placebos decrease
pain 1/3 of patients got better and
there are no side effects and doesn't
cost anything so as we're looking for
ways to increase the efficiency the
efficacy of medicine control cost I
think we need to look at how we speak
and how that can play a role in
improving patient outcomes so I want to
end with just the follow up of mr. Amato
and then I'm happy to take some
questions when I think back to my
communication mishaps with Omar Amadou I
can see more clearly how and why I was
so exasperated the geometry of our
conversation went awry as we pursue
divergent dialogues although I
appreciated the severity of his cardiac
disease I was irritated by the
muscularity of his insistence and
quickly picked him as a quote difficult
patient my labeling of him distorted
what I heard in his persistent demands
for my time I discerned entitlement I
became resentful had I stopped arguing
about appointments and phone calls with
him I might have been able to intuit the
animating impulse of his desperation
those of us whose luck has kept us from
facing down death can't really
appreciate the exquisite vulnerability
that serious disease and genders raw
fear is a motivating force like no other
when I tried to imagine being mr. Amadou
navigating an unforgiving medical system
negotiating in a foreign language all
over the heart that was flagging long
before its warranty was up I can begin
to understand his approach why wouldn't
he insist and what he perceived is
necessary
why wouldn't he refuse to take no for an
answer but I wasn't able to fully
comprehend that until his body crumpled
in my office and I felt the life working
away from him after his faulty pacemaker
was replaced and the excess fluid
drained from his lungs
mr. Amadou came for a post discharge
appointment it was an almost intolerable
relief to see his lanky frame in his
trusty tracksuit filling my doorway when
I shook his hand the hand that had been
frigid
time I'd held it I basked in its ardent
warmth I had no illusions of course and
neither did he
the recent tune-up did not impart any
fairy dust of additional cardiac reserve
mr. Amadou would not be doing the
200-meter dash down Lexington Avenue
anytime soon but we dodged the bullet
this time at least and we both exhaled
cautious sighs of relief mr. Amin whose
first question of course is when our
next appointment would be normally this
would irritate me but now his voice
unfurled almost like a benediction
I couldn't promise that we'd never have
miss communications in the future or
that I or he wouldn't get aggravated
when things didn't work out but I could
promise that I would pay more attention
how I listened and how I spoke my
favorite poet John Stone was a
cardiologist and poet from Emory who
sadly passed away a few years ago he
wrote his poem gaudium ziget or to a
graduating medical class some years ago
and amongst the many Sage lines he told
them you will learn to see most acutely
out of the corner of your eye do your
best with your inner ear a more astute
lesson in communication I could hardly
imagine thank you
thank you and happy to take any
questions yes sorry as a student of
public health and also as a patient has
anyone ever done a study on why
insurance companies ignore all of the
research that says that paying doctors
to spend more time talking to patients
reduces the need for all of these very
very expensive tests and things like
that like seriously I think it's a great
that's a great question I think
insurance companies probably don't read
much research but it really reflects
back and how our insurance system came
to be I mean this was put together when
you know in the early days of health
insurance and it was created by the AMA
in consultation with with insurance
company officials but in the setup there
the doctors who were specialists were
way over represented compared to primary
care doctors and so naturally things
that they did procedures or surgeries
got more money but also those are things
you can count and for insurance
companies you can count how many
endoscopy how many hours in the or how
many units of blood how do you count a
conversation how do you measure an
effective conversation and so we tend
toward paying for things we can count
and of course we had a fee-for-service
model so services things you did because
you cut things you put in holes got
money and things you talked about well
anyone could do that so that doesn't get
any money it's not considered service
but you're right and one could only hope
that when we redo our medical system we
think about that um cautiously
optimistic but I'm not holding my breath
thank you
so thank you for sharing some of your
book with us today I'm a pharmacist and
I definitely see the issue of
communicating with patients in everyday
life and there has been some kind of
push towards better care
you know Medicare star ratings for each
pharmacy that measure patient outcomes
rather than how many prescriptions you
filled for reimbursement thing is though
I just graduated they don't teach us in
school necessarily how to effectively
communicate with patients like even our
communications class had very specific
benchmarks we had to hit very specific
questions we had to ask without
necessarily being able to ask a question
based on the answer so how do you think
the education model should be tweaked
for healthcare professionals to a be
able to teach a class and have students
retain it thank you for that question so
how do we teach communication skills
which is critical in medicine we tend to
just like insurance companies we tend to
mark things that we can measure so we
make core competencies and we have a 1
to 5 Likert scale to measure did you
achieve this this level of competence
which again is easier when you're
measuring how someone does suturing hard
to measure when you're doing how they're
communicating and so our gut is always
to make a PowerPoint presentation on how
to communicate but I don't think that's
a very effective way to teach
communication and the real way to do it
is in the small setting with a role
model who shows how it happens and my
parallel is the issue of multicultural
sensitivity it's been a big push about
health care providers being you know
aware of our patient's various cultural
backgrounds and again we can do this
with PowerPoint presentations and I
remember as a student most of my
attendings were these older white men
with these starched you know white coats
all buttoned up who they never you know
went to the Peace Corps or travel in
Guatemala and I remember I'd bring them
to the bedside of her undocumented
Guatemalan immigrants or the you know
alcoholic from the
thinking how will these guys ever
connect but these old-school doctors
were very interested in the patient and
asked a lot of questions and did a very
thorough exam and they gave it the
patient's their full attention
and this curiosity and interest and
respect made the connection and so being
told oh oh Hispanics like this and
Asians like that it doesn't really give
the competency but listening carefully
and and paying attention really makes
that connection despite the cultural you
know golf that that occurs and I think
watching that watching these doctors
from very different stations and life
and backgrounds in the patient's
negotiate a connection was how I learned
it and so it's in the small group
setting it's also making choices who we
have as our teachers so we may tend to
want to get the specialist with the
great research you know in an area
because there they have a lot of
knowledge which is wonderful from one
part of medicine but we often forget
about bringing in those who can model
how to communicate and it might be the
nurse practitioner the pharmacist the
nutritionist the general practitioner
doctor who spends more time talking with
patients so it's an issue of doing it in
real time rather than having a slide
show and you can't do a multiple-choice
test on that but you can watch how our
students communicate one thing we
sometimes do is videotape them and I
once videotaped myself talking to a
patient and then watched it and I wish
amazed all these things I didn't realize
I did for example when I think hard I
closed my eyes I had no idea I could
always think of my sleep I don't get any
coffee
but I realized or I talked too much with
my hands but being able to watch
yourself as you talk with a patient is a
great way to see did you connect to
where you focused well you're making eye
contact and then our system is one of
the systems that I go through in the
book is called the rotor system of
communication which divides of all the
statements you make the statements that
questions of information questions of
explanation questions statements of
empathy questions of understanding and
then you can actually tally up how much
someone spoke and what they said what
the patient said and you can see boy the
doctor repeated the same thing
ten times but never once reassure the
patient and these are ways that we can
actually get better boy I'm missing the
boat on there another example is helping
patients take their medications
medication adherence so as we know
something like less than half of the
prescriptions we write get filled and
taken as the prescription says and some
of these medications are very important
so many patients are missing out on the
full benefit of that and so how do we
doctors respond we kind of her anger
patient well you've got to take them
you're gonna end up blind amputate in a
wheelchair you know you have a stroke
and heart attack and we bring out all
the the other horrific things and that
doesn't work very well but we keep doing
literally no any any other ways and a
wonderful study by Heidi Hamilton at
Georgetown she videotaped doctors and
patients speaking and then she
interviewed them both afterwards and
what was fascinating is that that all
the information about why the patients
couldn't take the medications were right
there but only in the post visit
interviews and the patients spoke
candidly about the cost of medication or
that a cause sexual dysfunction or that
it made them feel sick or they're
embarrassed used syringes in public or
they cut them and have to make them last
all these things that were the real
reasons they couldn't take medications
but it never came up in the in the
doctor-patient visit probably because
the doctors never asked you know and so
lesson I took from that sometimes when
in the middle of my harangue about you
know change a white rice to brown rice
more fruits and vegetables broccoli I
might stop and ask what's the hardest
thing about having diabetes and if I
remember to ask that the most important
things come out and and it could be the
social pressure as a family the walking
down the street and the food that's
cheapest is the worst food to eat
healthy foods more expensive things I
wouldn't know about and if we don't ask
we'll never find them out so there's
lots of aspects of communication that
can really improve health good evening
doctor hi at the risk of being booed I
worked for a lot of health insurers but
oh yeah okay so I just wanted to ask if
this is something that you covered and
you just sort of mentioned it I used to
work for a fin
health in the Bronx which is a Medicaid
payer and during our orientation they
showed a video and a lot of what you
just talked about were it was interviews
of patients and one of the things that
they talked about in terms of
non-compliance and medication and not
following through in courses of
treatment where they were embarrassed to
admit that they didn't understand what
the doctor had told them that the course
of treatment and they were ashamed to
say to the doctor I don't understand or
ask a follow-up question they felt
either they were earning the doctor
where they felt foolish or that the
doctor would look down on them is that
something that's come up in your book or
that in in studies that that they've
been able to talk I mean in it comes up
a lot but I have a patient who had very
difficult to control diabetes and his
medication adherence was terrible and so
every visit I would make this great
medication list I would write it clearly
an underlying colors and um and we were
getting nowhere and each visit I tried
harder to make a better and medication
list for him and explain each one go
through each one it took me more than a
year until he confessed to me that he
couldn't read and I'm making all these
lists for him and he can't read and he
was too embarrassed to admit that I
never asked and so for years this man
I've been going through life with a bag
full of medications so now one thing I
do to ask my patients very routinely you
know do you smoke do you drink how far
to go in school where you from and I'll
find patients who attend a third degree
from as far as third grade or fifth
grade a first grade and at least I'll
know that I need to be careful with
health literacy because they won't be
able to read the list of medications
things like that
so asking you know instead of saying are
you taking your meds which profession
say yeah I'll say you know many people
have trouble taking all their
medications it's very hard to do have
you ever had any difficulty taking some
of your medications and if I worried it
that way so I might be more likely to
say they don't take it my grandmother
may she rest in peace she believed
firmly in cutting every pill in half
whatever the doctor gave half
cholesterol thyroid and whatever it was
in half and I'm gonna what I'd say to
her she always cut it in half and I'm
sure doctors had no idea and she wasn't
doing it because of cost you
firmly believe that whatever they gave
was too much that you had a cut in half
and and in the end she ended up dying of
a sudden event in her home cardiac event
or a stroke and I fear was ending up in
a nursing home debilitated and you know
made me by cutting her you know her
statin in half
she didn't lower the cholesterol so much
so she got the heart attack rather than
sparing the heart attack ending up with
cancer or dementia so maybe she did the
right thing for herself and her doctors
probably never knew and so I I'm very
much more humbled now when I ask
patients about their medications because
there's loss that goes on medications
interact and we don't know if we don't
ask and and the patient has the
information we just need to know how to
ask in a way that's not so threatening
if you feel that they if you suggest
they bring somebody with them as we have
elderly parents and one can hear so well
or what I don't you know yeah I thinking
someone with you can be very helpful I
mean one one caveat is often if the
adults child of the elderly patient
comes the doctor often talks just to the
adult child and it's very and I it's
very tempting because that person speaks
more quickly and is more fluent in in
responding we have to be careful to
still address the patient to whatever
ability they have sometimes there's
dementia issues or hearing issues but
bringing some along can be very helpful
and you know the time-worn advice of you
know make a list before you come in but
to also recognize that if you have 40
things on the list if you do them all it
will be superficial and to be realistic
that you could really can only get to
three or four at most in any depth and
so prayer and prioritize and recognize
that you can hit a couple but not all
and you can get to some at another time
I also suggest that that patients at
least recognize that their doctors are
stuck in an untenable situation there's
a way more that must be done then can be
done in that time so you have no choice
but to multitask which is a terrible
thing to do it do they lose your
attention but you'll never finish and
then you'll get dinged for being
inefficient because you're running over
so one of the things I try to do is that
I find helps
is I try to let the patient talk for the
first minute without taking writing
anything down and then I'll say I don't
want to miss what you're saying do you
mind if I use the computer to write
while you're speaking so I can get it
all down then at least I'm acknowledging
your the necessary evil of the computer
we all know it has to be done but not
trying to sort of sneak away from the
patient and I'll just start writing over
over there and then at the end of the
visit to say is there anything else even
though we hate to say that as doctors
because you could be open the Pandora's
box but I think by asking that it lets
patients know that you know you you'll
have a chance to get it there you're not
going to be so anxious to get every last
little thing in so I encourage doctors
and caregivers to you know ask did I get
this right let me repeat back what you
said this is everything that you told me
one thing that could help improve
communication is for the patient to
bring a tape recorder or some kind of
recording device I have never done it
because I'm sort of you know oh I'm not
sure I don't know how the doctor would
react to that question and I wonder what
your opinion is and maybe the doctor
should also record for his or her own
benefit maybe it should be on the
instigation of the doctor and then give
a copy to the patient something like
that well some doctors will dictate in
front of the patient and then print out
a copy of the dictation and ideally
there was enough time to record a review
every visit but I think realistically it
wouldn't work for the doctor but I think
there could be some benefit my I take
cello lessons and my cello teacher
always wants me to record our lessons
and I never do because I'm going to go
back through ninety minutes of a tape
every time but I try to record if
there's a key moment you know although
let me just return that my tape recorder
just for that those two minutes I can
collect the key things that is helpful
to go back you'd be amazed at what you
forget so I think it might not be a bad
idea as long as you know both parties
are okay with it sure to give it a try
talking about you know going over things
with the patient's one thing that always
strikes me and a lot of doctor
do this is where they'll go over stuff
with you that happened during the
appointment but they won't go over the
discharge instructions so I went with a
friend of mine to Urgent Care the other
day and the doctor did a very good job
of asking her if she had any questions
or anything but then the the discharge
paper wasn't until you exited the office
and it was picked up at reception and so
we get home and she looks at it and she
says you know the doctor said to me that
if I wasn't feeling better in a few days
I should take this antibiotic because it
hit it had been she'd been prescribed
medication for an upper respiratory
infection and then a wait-and-see
antibiotic but on the discharge
instructions it says delayed or or
wait-and-see but it doesn't say how much
time and I looked at it and she was
absolutely right and so she had to while
feeling ill go find the number for the
urgent care call them back have them not
have the doctor's name and so on and so
forth and it this seems to be a problem
where discharge instructions tend to be
given to you outside of the doctor's
office by a reception so if there's
anything on it that confuses you the
doctors already off seeing another
patient and you have to you know wait an
hour and a half that's a great question
I think the point of leaving of parting
ways whether it's from a visit or from
the hospital is is a very fraught moment
and in fact when they interview patients
leaving the hospital most of them don't
even know their own diagnosis or their
doctor's name which is strikingly but
but they do know their nurses name
interestingly much more than their
doctor's name probably because nurses
spend more time in the room and are
touching more and so every time we sort
of part ways is a good you know time to
remind ourselves to stop and say okay
here are the top three things you have
to remember and here's my name I do that
again because the patient's forget I
forget their names I mean they forget my
name so to remind them again here's my
card my name is dr. o Frey and here's
how you can reach me if you forget
something we forget how much happens in
a visit and how hardest remember
especially if you're in pain or feel
sick or frightened it's very hard to
retain information so thank you for that
question
I believe we have time for one more
question
Thanks um I guess my question is really
is related to specific populations that
may have issues with memory or whether
it's something with Alzheimer's or it's
like TBI or if it's you know of all
different ages what is the doctors
responsibility in terms of ensuring that
there's compliance with with treatment I
guess if the patient themselves is not
reliable then who is it that steps in
you know to be able to do it if the
patient's not necessarily capable of
doing that on their own
that's a tough ethical quandary the
patient isn't able to do you know all
the things they need to do who steps in
it depends on the the level so if the
patient doesn't have decisional capacity
to make a decision that's a legal
definition in which case someone has to
be appointed legally a guardian then it
can make the decisions but short of that
you know if we if a patient you know has
capacity I has a basic understanding but
isn't quite taking the medications well
you can only try to help that patient
with getting a visiting nurse or or a
home attendant or encourage the family
but you can't really enforce anything
and and and you can't realistically
logistically be responsible for the
patient's taking that but it's trying to
help the patient get the services that
they want if they're amenable the I
problem I thought as a patient doesn't
want any services I don't want anyone in
my home I don't anyone coming near me
that's tricky I had a patient an elderly
woman who you know was it has a family
but she's really you know getting frail
and I suggested hospice and home hospice
and they were horrified the family
because that means death and and they
really didn't want to do it but then
they I can urge them to give it a try
they were so thrilled with the hospice
care it's been more than a year on
Hospice I spoke to I spoke to the family
this morning and the patient's doing
fantastically that the additional help
in fact improve the patient's
functioning and abilities much more so
sometimes is getting over the the stereo
our hospice means helping patients to
take that's that step and seeing that in
fact it usually makes things much
better but it's not always not always so
easy thank you so thank you very much
I'm happy to answer any more questions
on any books and thank you very much
have a wonderful evening
[Applause]